when did you first hear about the season
2 renewal
i found out on
it would have been the oh
20 like a week after the show came out
a week after show came out i had a
screening for my close friends and
family for
the wilds because we couldn't do a
premiere or anything because of covert
so we did a
private screening and it was that night
overnight i must have been sleeping when
it was happening in america
everyone was like i woke up and everyone
was like yeah going crazy about season
two and i was like what
like waking up hungover like trying to
figure out what was happening
so now i mean not much time has passed
since that but
is there any kind of shooting schedule
on the table do you know when you're
gonna have to get back into it
i don't know they i i have no idea
i'm i they think it's imminent i think
it's around the corner
i think they're trying to we're gonna
like get this done and dusted so that
everyone can get a season two as soon as
possible because i think yeah we all
just
love everyone's love for this show so we
want to like give them back a season two
as soon as possible so i think
everyone's doing
the best job they can and making that
happen i like hearing that
do you know have you been told anything
about
the future for shelby i know where ryder
wants to see shelby at the end
at the absolute end of the entire series
where she wants to see shelby and what
she wants to see she'll be doing so
i know that that's where she's going but
i've no idea what's going to be
happening in season two
i think i would have loved so much um
since the show released is seeing
everyone's theories
and reading everyone says i'm reading
some of these theories and i'm like oh
my god that's it
you know what i mean and there's some
that i'm like i didn't even realize
were happening that is so true and i'm
like a lot of these theories are really
spot on so
i i have one theory you could just sit
there and and react and we'll really
read into your reaction right now
take shock at the end i know that they
mention that she has food allergies but
i think she did it deliberately
well
that were you the happiest person in the
world when you read the script for that
episode and you were the only one who
didn't have to fake vomit
yes yeah i was it was a funny day
because everyone like in the hair makeup
truck like i just had all my normal
makeup which was still like
burnt and burned and stuff but they were
all like ghostly white like sick
makeup and they're all like drinking
like it was like miso soup and
it wasn't but not as nice as me it was
like miso super muesli bars and oh
random stuff but i also was a little bit
jealous because i was like god that kind
of looks really fun
i don't know there's something like fun
about being able to be like
like so we play it would you rather game
sometimes and one of my favorite
questions
is would you rather have to fake vomit
in a scene or fake
sneeze in a scene
i think fake vomit would be more
hilarious like
fake sneezing would be like
and i also think you've got there's so
much more room with fake vomit to have
fun there
like you can there's different sorts of
vomit vomits you can
you can do but it's like anything is
kind of one-dimensional
i don't know i'm gonna go vomit it's
difficult to do a convincing fake sneeze
but i guess also if you don't if you're
not like opposed to vomiting like some
people are just grossed out
and will really do it then yeah well i
guess yeah
that's another thing about the sneezing
thing that's like gosh it's
this simple action that everyone does
but it can be really easy to be
unconvincing so i'd be kind of scared to
do it i'd be like there's a lot of
pressure on this tank guys
gotta sneeze i'll give you
one broader season two question before
we move into random questions which is
how we end every episode of ladies night
is there any particular quality of
shelby's that you
are hoping to explore most in season two
oh definitely her sexuality and her
relationship with tony and
the relationship that she has with
herself and her god and who like her
sexuality i want i really want to see um
some growth there i think she's grown so
much already
so i don't want to put any pressure but
i think there's so much room there and i
i really want to see her just um
find comfort in herself and just not be
afraid to be who she is um
that's i i really want to see that for
her just personally
um because i love that about her
you